horizon forbidden west casts an imposing
shadow with its sheer size and density
but it's ultimately the characters and
stories you'll encounter that will drive
you to explore its new frontier the game
is continually compelling not because
developer gorilla games filled it with a
huge amount of stuff to do but because
so much of that stuff is thoughtfully
constructed and sometimes even
emotionally engaging instead of just
feeling like items created to add as
many map markers to a world as possible
forbidden west picks up almost
immediately after the end of the
original horizon and its dlc add-on
frozen wilds and it expects you to be
very familiar with protagonist eloy's
adventures from back in 2017. it's set
in the distant future after the world as
we know it has ended and humans have
reverted to a tribalistic society
scattered across the ruins of the united
states and roaming all around the world
are giant robotic animals some as big as
dinosaurs that kill humans on site
although eloy defeated the rogue
artificial intelligence hades in the
first game the damage it did to the
planet's biosphere means she's still
hunting ancient tech to fix the problem
that takes her into the afr mentioned
forbidden west in hopes of stopping a
blight slowly crossing the land
threatening everyone with starvation
since eloy is a hunter in a
hunter-gatherer society collecting
components to craft gear is a huge part
of the experience both for improving
your equipment and for keeping you
stocked in battle fighting huge powerful
machines is an exercise in identifying
weak points and using various kinds of
weapons and crafted ammo to strip away
armor while inflicting status effects
such as setting enemies on fire bathing
them with corrosive acid or freezing
them to make their metal bodies more
brittle
in a lot of ways forbidden west is
pretty much the same as zero dawn but
follows the common sequel ethos of more
and bigger and a lot of the systems have
been improved and expanded along the way
the horizon games include climbing and
environmental puzzles like those you'd
see in assassin's creed or uncharted but
in forbidden west much more of the world
is scalable to let you reach the tops of
mountains and ruins although this isn't
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
and you can't climb everything the
freedom still improves traversal quite a
bit however as does a powered grapple
that you can use to reach specially
marked points a glider that lets you get
down from those high places quickly and
the ability to swim and explore
submerged environments your arsenal is
larger with a bunch of different kinds
of weapons and elemental ammo types for
straight combat plus a series of
craftable traps that you can use to take
down machines and enemies before they
spot you and have a chance to fight back
there are so many weapons and options
that at times it's hard to keep it all
straight six huge skill trees replace
zero dawn's more modest four and each
focuses on a single element of eloy's
arsenal like traps hacking ranged combat
or stealth the skills you can unlock
include passive buffs and active special
moves for each weapon type
there's also a new set of powerful valor
abilities that feel similar to an
ultimate you might see in something like
overwatch or apex legends one valor
ability lets you turn on active
camouflage to go invisible and escape a
bad situation another amps up your
ability to slice off machine parts with
your weapons a third just creates a
blast of electricity around you to send
enemies flying
you can only equip one valor ability at
a time once you've unlocked it and you
have to charge it up through combat in
order to use it again it is a lot of
stuff to keep track of and the sheer
volume works against forbidden west as
often as it works for it for instance
you can buy weapons at every settlement
and each has a confusing name like shock
warrior bow or vanguard hunter bow most
of the time though it's not super clear
whether the uncommon shredder launcher a
merchant is selling is an upgrade over
the uncommon shredder launcher you
already have with so many ammo types in
the game you wind up carrying a bunch of
weapons to cover all the elemental bases
while not really caring about any one of
them it's only late in the game when you
start to find some demonstrably sick
weapons that the arsenal feels like
anything more than just a pile of junk
in your backpack that you have to dig
through until you find a bow that shoots
the right kind of arrows for a given
situation the massive skill tree
presents the same problem valor
abilities can be great in a pinch giving
you some next level power when you
really need it but there are two to
unlock on each skill tree and the use
cases for some aren't nearly as clear as
emergency invisibility cloak or 30
seconds of souped-up arrows the same
goes for the huge number of special
abilities which amounts to three for
each weapon type some are game altering
strategy centerpieces like the knockdown
shot but others are easy to forget about
like a skill that makes your slingshot
bomb more powerful if it bounces on the
way to your target in both cases you'll
probably unlock one or two you like and
stick with those for most of the game
that's also an issue with the flow of
combat forbidden west gives you more
options in a fight but it doesn't really
change battles fundamentally from zero
dawn it just throws more ingredients
into the stew you'll usually sneak into
a situation where a bunch of robots or
humans are gathered moving from tall
grass patch to tall grass patch to
either set traps snipe enemies or pull
off sneaky executions
once you've tipped off the machines to
your presence though combat can feel
flaily enemies have a tendency to attack
quickly and relentlessly and your only
defensive recourse is a dodge roll to
get out of harm's way so when a scrapper
or a wide mod charges you're dodging
attack after attack hoping to get a
little distance to draw an arrow and get
a shot off before you go back to fleeing
for your life it's also frustrating
trying to dig through your stupidly
large bag of traps and potions to find
an item that can heal you or cancel
status effects as again you're being
chased down by an apartment building
sized predator alloy has so much gear
and so many options at all times that a
lot of forbidden west's good ideas about
combat stealth trapping and crafting get
in the way of one another but when
you're able to make aloy's various tools
and abilities come together it creates
some harrowing and exciting battles
that's especially true when you're able
to make a plan with stealth traps and
tactics and execute it
it helps that while you fight a lot of
battles alone quite a few encounters
will see you aided by other characters
having an extra bow and more targets for
machines to chase lessens the pressure
and characters routinely chuck aloy
extra ammo to keep the fight going it's
those other characters that will keep
you going through forbidden west as much
as the opportunity to explore a
fascinating ruin or fell a rampaging
robo t-rex often you'll meet up with
someone from a local tribe who has a
vested interest in checking out that
long dormant agricultural testing
facility or space travel research lab
and it's in building relationships with
those characters and learning about
their various peoples that forbidden
west really shines even if ailoy herself
is kind of dull forbidden west puts
ailoy in an almost mass effect style
position of building a team to help her
save the world about a third of the way
into the game you establish a stable
base of operations and characters both
old and new become mainstays you don't
bring them out into the field as a unit
like an rpg team but you can head back
to talk with them about what you learn
and your experiences and they'll often
pair up with you at key moments or ask
your help with side quests that are
important to them the group grounds
forbidden west's story and gives you a
foothold in local events side quests are
also populated by interesting people
with relatable problems and motivations
it'll blow all the others out of the
forge
you have got to help me
and forbidden west does a great job of
giving you things to do that don't feel
like repetitions of the open world go
here get this quest template often
sidequests involve several steps or
multiple missions forcing alloy to
intervene in local politics or help with
a dire situation and they're not always
about combat in one series of missions
you wind up interacting with the leaders
of two desert villages each with
differing views about the future of the
tribe and distrusting of the other both
are likable but flawed characters and as
you spend a little time helping and
getting to know both you realize that
neither is wholly right or wrong the
investment of time and the solid writing
adds stakes to the situation that keep
you invested in its resolution
forbidden west is full of moments where
the game goes out of its way to put you
in close contact with a side character
for a bit and then turns them into the
fulcrum of an interesting quest paired
with the stakes of the main story this
gives the whole game the feeling that
you're not just running around doing
errands and odd jobs you're actually
building important relationships with
people you've come to know and respect
and while there are an absolute
truckload of side quests plus smaller
jobs to do many are well written and
offer a deeper look into forbidden
west's world
gorilla is also usually good at keeping
its various map filling activities
feeling fresh and diverse looks like
this door is locked
maybe there's another way in the game
contains a number of relic ruin sites in
which you explore a decrepit ancient
building looking for an artifact locked
in a hard to reach place there are a
bunch of these but i stopped to do each
one because they're fun and complex
climbing puzzles and they're all very
distinct from one another the same goes
for the tallnecks the giant robot
dinosaurs that serve the map revealing
function of towers in other open world
games reaching the top of each lumbering
robot is a puzzle unto itself one is
submerged in the ocean and requires you
to find components to rebuild it for
instance and another can't be reached
until you knock it over by shooting it
with giant ballistas the general goal is
always to get to the top of a tall neck
but each challenge is so different from
the others that they're absolutely worth
chasing down as soon as you reach a new
area
to other machines
and now it's mine the main story also
has its share of standout moments one
portion concerns helping the leader of
the tanakh to put down a rebellion so he
can make attempts at peace and
cooperation with the tribes in the east
another takes you into a submerged
underground las vegas strip to help some
salvagers realize their dream of
elevating their traveling storytelling
act with technological wonders the story
can be uneven at times but it's often
good at keeping the focus on stakes that
feel like they actually matter to the
people involved
the storytelling is aided by the fact
that forbidden west is absolutely
gorgeous on playstation 5 in both its
graphics and its performance mode
everything from the characters and their
intricately constructed armor to the
rusting ruins of cities with rebar
jutting out of concrete to the lush
jungles and windswept deserts is
impressively detailed catching a sunrise
over the farms of plainsong or the waves
of landfall is legitimately beautiful
and the colorful diverse locations offer
vista after stunning vista everywhere
you look it's a very pretty game
characters benefit from a great deal of
strong voice work and what seems like an
abundance of scanned facial performances
if not outrightful motion capture with a
hose to a compressed air capsule hammer
and tongue what is this what is
happening here
get over here you'll spend a large
amount of time in conversations in
forbidden west and in the main quest and
big side quests the characters are often
compelling because their facial
performances are so good this has a
drawback though you'll definitely notice
the less important folks who move like
animatronics and in some interactions on
lesser missions eloy has a tendency to
look all over the place as if her
animation isn't quite matched to that
particular conversation or circumstance
maybe i can help
for the big important moments though a
ton of characterization and emotion
comes through in the faces and it makes
the stories and emotional beats of the
game all the more interesting the vast
size of forbidden west also feels like
it introduces a fair few technical
issues beyond aeloy's occasional
inability to make eye contact with less
interesting characters especially when
you're on a mount or looking over large
distances there can be some texture pop
in particularly with the architecture of
settlements the game crashed to the
playstation dashboard on me a handful of
times as i played through it and a
couple of times
a quest couldn't be completed until i
reloaded an earlier save aloy got stuck
looting a chest or an enemy a few times
forcing me to roll back to an earlier
save and she got stuck in the sky and in
the ground on a couple of occasions too
none of these issues were game breaking
for me and forbidden west auto saves
liberally so i never lost much if any
progress a day one patch seems to have
ironed out a few of the pre-release
issues i experienced but while some of
them have been lessened like the texture
pop-in problem they haven't been
eliminated
overall though horizon forbidden west
does a lot more right than it does wrong
it might be jam-packed with stuff to see
do know and remember but when its many
systems come together it can be a
beautiful exciting and delightful open
world experience the story that drives
you through the frontier is often well
told and does well to center actual
characters rather than audio logs and
while the map is littered with icons
it's much more often that they're fun
skillfully crafted diversions than
random busy work to fill a checklist
there's a huge amount to see and do in
horizon forbidden west and the great
majority of it is worth doing and seeing
thanks to strong writing great visuals
and some marked improvements to the
series underlying ideas
[Music]
[Music]
you